في الذكرى الاولى للحرب بوتينسكي تحدثها
وكان الحرب لم تبدا بعد اهداف الرئيس
الروسي هي نفسها اوكرانيا بشكلها الحالي
لا تستحق الوجود النازيه لم تعد دمها
الوحيد واراضيها اصبحت ميدان حرب الوكاله
يحركها
الغربود الشيخ
اكبر الداعمينسكي بايدن لم يترك رمزيات
الذكرى رهينه لكلمه بوتين تجول في شوارع
كييف تحت صافره انذار وهميه
رساله حملت دعما معنويا يتعدى تاثير
السلاح اداره اراده الاوكرانيين وحدها
اوقفت بوتين عند تخوم كييفا قبل عامه
مواصله الحرب
[موسيقى]
اذا هي واشنطن مواصله الحرب حتى اخر
اوكرانيا هكذا ترى موسكو الامر بينما تضخ
امريكا المال والسلاح وتدفع اوكرانيا
ضريبه بقائها بالدماء فرصتان لم تحلم بهما
واشنطن من قبل اضعاف روسيا واحياء الناتو
هنا يجب العوده الى الواقعيه خلصت روسيا
اهدافها تدريجيا طوال عام الى تقدم بات
يحسب بالامطار لا شيء مقارنه بما يقترب
النيتو من تحقيقه
1350 كيلو مترا من فنلندا تضاف الى حدوده
مع روسيا لكن مع المراوحه العسكريه
الروسيه جاءت مفاجاه اقتصاديه الانكماش
بعد عام من الحرب لم يتعدى
2.1% معجزه في زمن الحرب والعقوبات غير
المسبوقه اكثر من 14
توجد موسكو بلقب الدوله الاكثر تعرضا
للعقوبات في العالم والروبل صمد باعتراف
واشنطن
مفعول العقوبات عكسي رغم ان اوروبا تجاوزت
الشتاء باقل الخسائر هذا في التصريحات
الرسميه اما في الواقع فالتضخم افاق قدره
الاوروبيين لينعكس ذلك على تعهدات بلدانهم
لكياب حصلت على اربعين في المئه فقط من
المساعدات المعلنه
مساعدات اضافيه لا تقل عن 33 مليار يورو
بحسب عده تقارير التقارير ذاتها تشير الى
انك يفقد حصلت على اقل من نصف الاموال
التي وعدت بها العمل الماضي حيث حصلت
وزاره الماليه الاوكرانيه على 31 مليار
يورو من مجموع 64 مليار كانت قد وعدت بها
ما يؤخر وصول المساعدات الغربيه لاوكرانيا
سريعا هو الاجراءات المعقده لدى الغرب
فالاتحاد الاوروبي يحتاج احيانا لما يزيد
عن سته اشهر كامله للحصول على بعض
الموافقات القانونيه والسياسيه لبعض
المساعده الماليه القياده السياسيه
الاوكرانيه من جهتها تقول ان هذا التاخير
يمثل مشكله كبيره لا سيما عندما تكون في
خضم حرب وان على الغرب الا ينسى انك لا
تدافع عن نفسها فقط وانما تدافع عن كامل
الاراضي الاوروبيه